the bitcoin market had another wild week
there's contagion everywhere the price
keeps dipping down below 20 000 and
everyone's asking what the hell is going
on with the decentralized digital
currency well in this week's update
hopefully we'll clear up all those
answers don't forget that now this
weekly update is brought to you by ftx
us click on the link in the description
to go check them out all right let's get
into it and start looking out at bitcoin
first what we can see here is that
bitcoin trading just above 19 000 right
now then we can go and take a look at
the actual network itself and what we
see there is that the market cap is now
trading well below 400 billion dollars
we know that the inflation rate is only
at 1.76 percent which is in deep
contrast to the u.s dollar inflation
rate somewhere around eight and a half
percent the supply of bitcoin issued
into the circulating supplies stands at
90
and of course real exchange volume is at
5.46 billion dollars over the last 24
hours we know that miners their revenue
has been dropping drastically they're
only being paid about 17.7 million
dollars in the last 24 hours to continue
to secure the most powerful computer
network in the world gbtc premium has
actually flipped to a discount and has
been widening at an aggressive rate and
now sits at minus 36 to nav and of
course bitcoin down about 72
from its previous all-time high back in
november
then we can go ahead and we can take a
look at price comparison between bitcoin
gold and the s p 500 bitcoin down 43
from just one year ago gold sitting at
plus one percent and the s p 500 down 13
but over any other timeline between two
years and 10 years bitcoin has
drastically outperformed these other
assets then we can take a look here and
see the closing history of bitcoin 557
days out of all of bitcoin's life it's
actually closed at a higher level that
means for 88 of bitcoin's life if you
had bought it and held it till today you
would be in profit if we line up bitcoin
compared to assets like gold s p 500
nasdaq and tlt we can see that the
compound annual growth rate over the
last decade sitting at 122 percent
drastically outperforms any of the other
assets we can also see that the five
year sharpe ratio at over one is
something to continue to make it an
attractive asset as to why people may
want to put it into their portfolio now
of course these individual network
metrics and things around the price
itself only tell one part of the story
if we take a look at block blockwear
doing some great research over there in
their newsletter on a weekly basis we
can see that they've taken a deep dive
with will clemente on all the on-chain
analytics let's get right into what
they've got in terms of the monthly
performance of bitcoin the last two
months it's the worst stretch in the
history of bitcoin not something to
celebrate we then can take a look and
will's been talking about the death
spiral of tara luna for quite a while
his question all the way back in may was
where will the contagion show up from
the ust meltdown how many crypto funds
and projects we're holding ust how many
custodians lending clients funds in
anchor etc this is crypto's bear stearns
lehman brothers moment but here there
are no government bailouts and that was
quite a forward-looking thing we can see
a lot of the problems showing up across
the market all sorts of margin calls and
unraveling of tons and tons of leverage
this is showing you the market caps and
how they're coming d-pegged or decoupled
from all of those altcoins then next we
can look at the exchange net position
change and what we see here is because
so much complexity is in the market
there's so much fear and uncertainty
people are nervous this is the largest
depletion of coins from exchanges in
bitcoin's history according to blockware
next up we can see the capitulation
being reflected across realized losses
net unrealized profit and loss and spent
output profit ratio here we have the
entity adjusted net unrealized profit
and loss down big next up we can see
that the net realized profit loss also
significantly down and then lastly you
can see the entity adjusted sopro with a
14 day moving average also falling off a
cliff
after that we can go and see that the
capitulation from miners it's already
here we continue to see lower bitcoin
price driving higher hash rate and
difficulty and higher energy costs that
puts the pressure on those miners and
their margins hash price is now its
lowest since october of 2020 according
to will and hash ribbons have crossed
and now it's showing that miners are
feeling the pressure and a lot of them
are gonna have to unplug their machines
and they might have to sell some of
their coins as well but one bright spot
in all of this it's murad posting this
chart right here in his return to
twitter showing that there is a ton of
dry powder in the top you have the
bitcoin price going down at the same
time you can see usdt and usdc two of
the leading stable coins tons and tons
and tons of dry powder sitting on the
sidelines just waiting to be deployed
into bitcoin once people feel like we're
at the bottom
next up we can see that bitcoin's market
price is now below the realized price
looking here at the mv rv z score and
that means the market capitalization
based on the last time coins were moved
on chain is higher than where the price
is today the market's underwater in
aggregate and that shows and a lot of
people look at these as buying
opportunities of course we can take a
look at the four year trend only the
fourth time ever bitcoin is trading
below that four year trend that signals
somewhere near a bottom in the past
about three percent of bitcoin's
existence has traded below where it's
200-day moving average and below
realized price as well well that's where
we sit right now so that gives us a
sense that we are at very very depressed
levels from a price to value standpoint
and a lot of people are starting to get
excited
now of course nobody knows what the
future holds but what we do know is over
the last couple of weeks there has been
massive chaos across the market
bitcoin's price has fallen off a cliff
and we continue to see contagion
throughout the market there are multiple
centralized lenders who are in trouble
and there's also a ton of pressure from
funds at the end of the first half of
the year going ahead and selling their
assets rebalancing or giving redemptions
to their lps where we go from here is
anyone's guess but a massive part of it
is the macro environment and the federal
reserve's continued commitment to go
ahead and conduct quantitative
tightening they're raising interest
rates and they're selling assets off
their balance sheet that macro story
overlaid on the micro story of bitcoin
has a lot of people paying attention
they want to understand what exactly is
going to occur in the next three days
the banks are closed for the july 4th
weekend here in the united states of
america and that means that a lot of
people aren't gonna be able to get fiat
currency on to the crypto exchanges the
last time we had a three-day bank
holiday all of a sudden the prices fell
pretty significantly was it because of
the bank holiday or was it because of
the contagion in the market it's hard to
parse those two things apart and so pay
attention this weekend we'll see what
happens but i think that there should be
some pressure downwards on the bitcoin
price of course that doesn't mean that
bitcoin's going to zero it's not going
to disappear all we are watching is
short-term pressures at the expense of
the long-term viability of bitcoin
bitcoin is not going away bitcoin will
continue to do exactly what it was
designed to do strongest computer
network in the world it has a
programmatic monetary policy there's a
lot of people around the globe who find
that incredibly valuable now speaking
around the globe ftx one of the best
exchanges in the crypto world they've
got services for both people
internationally and here in the united
states if you're interested in buying
bitcoin with very very cheap fees you
can go ahead and test out ftx us you can
click on the link in the description
their fees are sometimes as much as 85
percent lower than their competitors
they've also added things like digital
stock trading in beta where you can go
ahead and you can buy stocks on the same
exchange there's no transaction fees and
there's no payment for order flow as
they try to get you the best pricing
available check out fdx us they make
this video possible every single week by
supporting them you support us i hope
you guys enjoy these weekly updates and
we'll go ahead and see you guys next
saturday hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time